five rounds but apparently not for
Wesley but he is now Gathering some
steam because this is round seven and he
will be on plus two
after seven so definitely becoming
becoming a contender which year did he
win like 2000 uh he won uh 18 19 around
that uh 17 17 or 17 yeah and meanwhile
Peter we do have a result that we see on
the camera just there Magnus has won
Richard resigns yeah just show the last
few moves of that game yeah so uh in
that position after 92 Richard played
between a five among just went up in H3
and uh yeah
uh Richard not very interested in trying
to defend this it's not really very
defendable
he doesn't really like wasting anybody's
time so
I assume after 92 you could maybe keep
the Queens on but the result still isn't
really very much in doubt kuna Fife is
another one of those moves where it
feels like you've sort of checked out
you you no longer care about